the second method is it's you name it
sounds very impressive and actually by
rights it's a it's a method that
whatever the extension to students need
to know however it's actually kind of
handy to keep up your slate as an
extension one student becomes really
useful when you solving related rates
pressure to sweet shop things like I am
I'm pouring in an amount of what up into
like a basin and write that which I
poured the water off is related to the
rad which the water increases inside
line basically I've got one right here
I've got another great here they're
related to each other so this method of
entry is funny connected to that it's
called implicit differentiation
I think the name how honestly was made
up by someone who wanted to sound cool
it's like all this is actually it's just
a dressed-up name for the chain rule
that's why in extension listen there's
no reason why make sense you're my
student
okay what we're going to do is you know
what unlocked everything was getting in
terms of diversity okay when you look at
this that's not the only way to do it
right like you can get things in terms
of Exponential's or remember we said be
on this side of Exponential's is logs
yes so this is another way to do it so
instead of reframing it in this plane
from the first line I'm going to take
logs of both sides
now how you taking logs of both sides
this is advantageous to us and it can
make progress because of one of the laws
that I know I sort of hijacked it over
here as well namely that not only do I
don't have a different share
monsterschool star but also over here
one of the lot laws can help me out and
get rid of what made this an awkward
problem for which log wall can I see
that would be useful it's the it's the
power right this power up here can climb
out the front become the coefficient
okay so I can write this as X X so I've
gotten rid of the X to the X problem
okay I got rid of it in a different way
but it's really just looking it from
another angle
let me end up with a long one okay now
this is kind of progress but then it's
like whoa well now what do you do you
have two choices okay from there if you
like you can actually do this did you
see that you see what I've done right so
I'm using the same law just reducing it
in a different way I can rewrite this as
an exponential equation and off I go
okay but he comes the implicit
differentiation pot right what I'm gonna
do now is I have a functional left I
have a function of the right I'm just
gonna differentiate both sides of the
equation with respect to X just like I
took criticized equation landed I took
logs of both sides do the same thing
here okay so I say what's the derivative
of this thing with respect to X and
what's the true of this thing
with respective X okay now this looks
weird for a couple of reasons but we'll
get to that reason in a second let's do
the easy pumpers the right hand side Z's
do you agree the right hand side is just
is just a rule
in fact just because I think it's
questions a minute ago I know exactly
what the drew this is it was my inside
function over here that's not a
coincidence by the way okay so being
that I know what that is I'm just gonna
call it okay it is just log X plus
that's what I ended up with after do the
punt rule and simplify out now have a
look at this guy okay this is a bit more
weird but it's not that weird
in fact I have the exact answer is
already written on the board I'm gonna
try and make a little ball obvious why
right it's not just the letter
it's not just a pretty implies a on Y is
all function right so when we try and
make it obvious that something is a
function we say Y is a function of X
yeah like just using the letter Y as
just our sort of shorthand for that we
get sick of writing a little time but
really this is the case now do you see
that I'd already know what happens when
you differentiate log of a function I in
fact chain rule right it's the function
of a function makes sense so in fact
what I have here is y dash on why do you
agree with that does that okay like all
I've done is differentiate a log
function and it happens that my function
is called Y could be called f or it
could be cold right now whatever you
want okay it's just a label right right
now it makes that's a scary okay brother
this is a strange that I'm kind of
mixing up on my language here instead of
writing there's no right to the left
hands on it the language that I'm using
is more about damn DX and I only
introduce this bracket X
function notation later really only
solution instead that very here I'm
going to write the numerator which is
the derivative of Y with respect to X
that's what it is and the denominator is
just Y that is my meter wave right it is
I only wrote like to see you breaking my
chain all right count now you should
pause for a moment this line here is
like here this is where it gets its name
okay it's called implicit
differentiation because this derivative
that I want that's what I'm trying to
solve for right I didn't get it directly
I'm just kind of appeared right because
when I use chain rule it has to appear
because I've got to differentiate the
inside function and I made why the
inside function okay so the demand EXI
marks are just kind of pops up right now
I can solve this I've got dy DX already
on the left hand side but to get it by
itself I've been a multiplying both
sides by Y which happens to be X to the
X right so in one fell swoop
tada there's my derivative there which
you already knew now which way do we
prefer I think in this question I
personally I find implicit
differentiation I kind of unnecessarily
complicated okay it works obviously but
this kind of there's sort of mental
gymnastics you need to do here is kind
of like why why do that it worked just
fine using like lowest stuff that you
know I saw this great image the other
day which is that a good mathematician
uses the strongest tool available to
solve the problem but a great
mathematician uses the weakest tool
available it's a bit like okay I need to
like slice some bread that's okay I have
a chainsaw in the garage right you don't
do that use this little thing cuz it's
all you need right this is all you need
you don't need to
really crazy stuff like this unless you
want to sound cool it's out of order you
could buy a visit okay I won't mention
like I said complicit become more useful
later it becomes very very handy where
there's no like what do we do
what was the piece of knowledge to help
us do this remember it was about
Exponential's and this identity okay
or correspondingly is about log floors
right now if you don't have
Exponential's and logs if you've got
trig functions or goodness we'll get to
those inverse trig functions then much
messier to do when there aren't such
nice neat balls that will pop things out
into a form it's easier to differentiate
so you have to appeal to something like